And I think this does conclude our special called BFA Committee
meeting. So. Thank you, Controller. We will now begin our
Controller's Office Budget Workshop. So,
Controller, I believe at this time we're going to invite your Deputy Director,
Leonard Polk, up for his presentation and give
him a moment to get settled. And thank you again, Controller, for your
words of wisdom.
Okay. And I think
our presentation is all queued up and essentially
ready to go, so we're a little ahead of schedule, but we're
doing great. So go ahead. You don't want to take a 20 minutes?
No, we're going to get right into it. We're going to get right into it.
I used to be in that chair. I remember how important it is to move
people through. Yes, sir. Thank you. Okay.
On behalf of the 53 almost employees working tirelessly to
protect our City's fiscal health, I'm pleased to present the proposed
FY 23 budget for the Office of the City Controller.
As mentioned, Deputy Director Leonard Polk is here to assist me
in answering some of the more detailed questions, but we'll
go ahead and get
into the presentation. First and foremost, the mission
of the Controller's Office is project the financial integrity of
Houston's municipal government. To accomplish this, the Office
is responsible for managing all payroll and vendor payments,
conducting audits, managing a $5 billion investment
portfolio and a $14 billion debt portfolio, which we do in
house, preparing accurate and timely financial statements,
providing fiscal leadership on policy issues relating to the City's
financial health. We are the independent authority to
conduct performance reviews and audits of the City's Departments,
and we assess the City and region's future financial outlook with
accurate forecasts of projected revenues and expenses, among other indicators.
As we'll discuss today, the proposed budget for FY 23 totals
$8,954,843,
and that represents
an increase of 2.5% from the fiscal year
22 budgeted amount of $8,730,277.
So this increase represents a net change of $224,566,
and that's primarily
attributable to rising amounts in restricted accounts.
So the increase in pension contributions, contractual pay
raises for municipal employees as well.
Of the total proposed operating budget,
84%, or $7,548,436
of expenses, are associated with personnel costs. So,
similar to the overall City, the Office of
City Controller does not have revenue to report, and there
is no change in the FTE count from FY 22 to FY
23. So looking at if
we can go back sorry, one slide and the chart.
Looking at our organizational chart, the Controller's Office.
We have six divisions that help protect the fiscal well being of the City,
its enterprises, and its component units. Our Operations Division
is the workhorse of the six and responsible for making sure City employees
and vendors get paid. Our Treasury Division
is responsible for managing a 5 billion investment portfolio
and a $14 billion debt portfolio. Again, both of those are
done in house without outside managers. And our
Audit Division is responsible for the audit functions of the City, including managing
fraud, waste and abuse hotline. In total, the FY
23 proposed budget of 8.9 million helps the
nearly 53 Controller Office team members across six
divisions accomplish these key tasks.
Next slide.
To highlight the roles and responsibility of the Controller's Office,
we provide financial oversight of city operations.
We develop financial reports such as the Monthly Financial Report and
the annual Comprehensive Financial Report, the annual audit,
and perhaps most importantly, we process payments
to vendors and employees. And as
defined in the City Charter, the Controller's Office is responsible for
certifying the availability of funds for council action and
the audit functions of the City and its reporting units. Next slide.
So, as we mentioned previously, we don't have any revenue to report.
So we'll go to the next slide, and again no
revenue report. So we'll move on to slide six.
So the total proposed budget of 8.9 million is 2.5%
higher than the FY 22 budgeted amount.
The FY 21 actual is 7,813,000
946,000. And you can see the FY 22
budgeted is $8,730,277.
So the variance on those is 224,566,
again, previously mentioned 2.57%.
So we've seen a decrease in funding available for the audit
function and that is something that I know we've discussed around this council
table. Between the term
or retirement pay and competitive edge among audit
practitioners when compared to the private sector, our audit division
is doing more with less.
And we'll move on to the next slide.
We can see the total proposed operating budget.
84%, or seven and a half million of expenses,
are associated with personnel costs. And of
the remaining 16%, 1.4 million,
a majority of expenses, 1.3 million. Of that 96%
are associated with other services and charges.
Next slide. In looking@the.net
change to the FY 22 current budget,
the FY 23 proposed budget includes an increase of $51,970
as a result of service chargeback accounts for items such as fuel,
electricity. It counts. It accounts an
increase of 139,209
as a result of municipal pay increases through the Hope contract,
and a decrease of $9,090 due
mainly to health benefit adjustments. So we're projecting
a decrease of 4000 in auditing services.
We have an increase of 20,000 for miscellaneous
support services, a decrease of 20,000 for information
resource services, and a decrease of 5000 for
miscellaneous other services. Next slide.
We see a major decrease in health insurance for active civilian
personnel and that would be a reduction of $42,506.
And we saw
the increase of 134,141
seen in the FY 23 Hope salary adjustment. And that's attributable
to the contractually obligated pay increases that were
negotiated earlier this year. Next slide.
So, in summary, expenditure increases are attributable to rising
amounts and restricted accounts. So it's really not anything that we're adding.
It's all nondiscretionary. Those are increased pension contributions,
contractually obligated, municipal employee pay increases.
We've really tried to manage our budget very efficiently.
I think we and Leonard sometimes gets frustrated
with me, but we always go under budget. We're trying to be
a good taxpayer steward. But I would say,
in closing, if you look at the comparable amount of auditors
to other Texas cities, namely Dallas, San Antonio, Austin,
we're well below the number of auditors. And again, we talked about
in the previous presentation about making investments to kind
of save recurring money in the future.
We've been and historically shown that we can find
and utilize savings for the city through our audit division.
So I would say some of the unmet
needs I know people have asked about, that we
really need more auditors. So we'll move on to the next slide that's
questions. Thank you very much, Controller. I believe that
covers quite a bit here and we've got a couple of council members in the
queue. We'll start with Council member Sally Alcorn. Thank you,
Chair. You don't have any revenues,
but you make a lot of money for the city and treasury and investments.
Can you talk about that? About what, like rate of returns
for the past year? Yes,
overall, we have seen interest rates
rising. It's been, quite frankly, a little bit of a challenge in
our investment fund. When you look at the yield curve and
as rates rise, that yield curve tends to slope up positively.
You have a principle of duration and that's the time that your investment
is locked in. It's been a little bit of a dance to try
and get that duration perfectly matched to beat
the benchmark. We continue to think that rates are going to continue to rise,
so we don't want to lock in something at 3%
and rates go to 4% because then we leave money on the table.
Equally complicating is the increase
in rates on our debt portfolio, because the opportunities to refinance
are now getting less opportune.
Luckily, again, my background in investment banking, eight years
working for an investment bank that primarily did fixed income,
I knew that this low interest rate environment was going to be a huge opportunity
for the city of Houston. We have
to date received over $600 million
in interest rate savings from refinancing
the city's debt. We've been very aggressive with this.
Other cities have been successful.
I think Houston is maybe one of the most successful. We are one of the
largest cities, so that number is quite high. But those
opportunities are probably going to be less
opportune going forward. But it's great that we did this,
because when you look at that and that's city wide,
but on average, a period of around 15 years
of a weighted average. So this is $30
million, $40 million a year that
the city is not paying in debt service. So that's savings.
We'll continue to identify those and be aggressive. It's just in this
particular environment and it all goes up and down. Eventually,
maybe the rates will come back down. We'll have more opportunity.
Thanks. Thank you, council member. And thank you, Controller.
Next we'll hear from council member Amy Peck. Thank you. And thank you,
Controller. Related to the reduction
in your audit division. As you know, I want to see more audits
in the city and not fewer. So can you talk a little bit about what
that reduction will mean in terms of how many fewer audits
or what you're able to do less with the
reduction? Yeah. So we'll
use council office as an example. Those of you all
council members have seen through these tough times
with COVID and other reductions in
overall expenditures, especially with costs
like health care and pension and all these other things rising.
Unfortunately, we have not been able to invest as much as we'd like to
in the audit division. We would love an
example of a great opportunity,
if there was a way to find some of this federal money, to go out
and hire more auditors. I was looking
in my notes. Houston has about
ten. We have ten auditors or ten total staff in our audit division.
Austin has 28, Dallas has 20,
san Antonio has 23. And so
per employee, houston has one auditor per 2122
employees, austin has one per 550.
Dallas has one per 700, and San Antonio has one per 500.
So they're a lot more in line. So just
to wrap up, if someone wanted to and I've made this plea
before if someone wanted to offer a budget amendment to fund
more auditors using some of the fungible ARPA money,
I think that would be a worthwhile investment. And I can tell you that if
you look at the amount of savings versus the audit budget,
it's a great return on investment. We spend a million and a half dollars
a year in audit, but during the time I've
been in office, I think now over 11 million in savings.
So, again, I think it's a good investment, and I think with a
bigger team, we could take on bigger audits and be more
effective in finding efficiencies for the city.
Thank you, Controller. That amendment is already on my list. All right, thank you.
Thank you. Wish come true. We got a follow up question from Council Member Alcord.
Thank you. It's my understanding we're not to submit budget amendments for ARPA money,
but not to say that that won't happen.
And then I was going to ask you about the paper reduction.
I am a firm believer that the city still uses citywide
entirely too much paper. And can you talk about what you're doing with the
invoices and how you really are trying to go paperless in
the Controller's office? Yeah, great question.
We've been working on this for some time.
Curiously, Harvey actually pushed our hand on a lot of these things.
We've moved to DocuSign to digitally sign a lot
of contracts, so that eliminates the movement of paper
in the Controller's office. We have moved to eliminate paper checks
and reduce invoices. There's still some work to do
to get truly paperless invoices. And just like with the DocuSign,
when we went through that process, we had five different departments
that wanted to use each their own system. And in order
to properly memorialize those signatures, everyone needs
to be on the same system. We were able to essentially get everyone to have
buy in. We'll need a little bit more buy in from all the departments to
get truly paperless invoicing. But I would say that that is the
future. I think even around the council
table and us still signing a lot of these contracts that
are paper, I know Leonard helps
in every week going through with our team to
sign off on all these contracts, but they're paper contracts that are being physically moved.
And I would say that that's something that could be a huge savings
for the administration to move to a truly paperless system.
It's difficult to transition, but a lot of the other cities
and smaller cities in this region, sugar Land, Paralym,
Woodlands are using Or, Sugar Land and Pearland are using
these types of systems. So something I think is a great idea. Thank you
very much. And thank you, I think actually for the TTI committee,
we've heard from the Houston Information Technology System
about such technology being embraced and hopefully soon incorporated.
So again, Controller, thank you for your remarks. I believe that's the
end of our questions from council and staff.
And with that we will move. I just wanted to take a point of
personal privilege, please. I do have some staff members. If you'd
recognize your team, that'd be great. You guys are always welcome. And I know
we are in constant communication with many of you, but I wanted to
recognize our Chief Deputy City Controller, Shannon Nobles,
our Chief Operating Officer, and Deputy Controller
Alex Obergon. Vernon Lewis is our Treasury
Analyst, john Seideler is our Communications Director,
and Sharice Mosely, who heads our Treasury Division. I want to just thank
them and Leonard, as you all know,
this is a lot of work and we a lot of times get up here
and talk and look good, but it's these people that get us ready
to be able to do the things that we do. So thank them and thank
you all for your time today. Thank you, Controller. We know you have a great
team and we appreciate all the work you all do upstairs.
Thank you again. We've got two public speakers,
both of whom we believe are online virtually and
prepared with a question. And we'll start with Ms. Saba Blanding.
Good morning. Good to ask you all some
more questions today. Good morning.
My question is, and this is, I believe, directly to
council members, if you could add one to
2 million to the current budget,
if that magically appeared, what department and or service would
you fund and why? Well,
I appreciate that question and we'll commit
it to the record. Ms. Blanding, thank you for that. I don't see any
council members jumping to respond, but it is
an interesting question, and we will consider what we would
do with an extra million or $2. Thank you
for that. Appreciate you being here today. Thanks.
And next, we'll hear from Mr. Jason Oliver.
Mr. Oliver, if you're with us on mute.
Yes, I'm here. There you are. Go ahead, sir.
So my first question is to the controller.
Thank you for the presentation. Where are we in terms of the Checkbook
program implementation? Is the data and
information prepared? Some of us, if that information
is available, some of us in the public would be interested
in working on a version of it, depending on the city's timeline.
So we're trying to get an estimated time of completion
for that. And then the second question is
to Council Member Robinson. You had mentioned that policy budget
amendments will be out of order. I'm trying to figure out why the
restriction on budget amendments this year.
We're going to start with your first question, Mr. Oliver. Let's see if
the controller has something to respond. So the
now Open Finance, what we previously
dubbed the Checkbook, that program
that we started was started and halted and then
restarted about a year later.
From the most recent report I've seen, there's about 40% of the project
that's been complete. I think the deadline is September,
October of this year. But we
would like to see that project completed and done because
I think, again, there'll be a lot of opportunity to
scrutinize expenditures and maybe find some more efficiencies.
If not only the Controller's office but council
and every citizen of Houston has the access to see in real time every
expenditure, not just vendor payments, but payroll
and other expenditures. So we've been
cautiously optimistic that this project will get online. I would
just add the genesis of this whole exercise
was a joint effort between the mayor's office and
the Controller's office to utilize and
be eligible for a transparency star, which is the State
of Texas financial transparency ranking system.
And you get stars for different accomplishments.
Namely, the first one has to be putting all
of your expenses online. We're the only major city in the country that
doesn't have our payments online. But unfortunately,
we will not be eligible even if we do the Open Finance project
for that transparency star. We'll continue to be the only major
city in the country without the transparency
star, in the sense that if you don't have five years of historical
data, you don't qualify for the star. So I don't believe that the
Open Finance has agreed to be able to put that historical information.
It's something that we included in our project. So I
would say I'm hopeful that the project will go
online. I think it's going to be a great tool for not only council and
staff, but also for citizens of Houston. And as a taxpayer,
I want to be able to have this tool available to
me, but we also need to push to put that historical data on
there so that we are eligible to get that first transparency star,
because the other stars we're already doing.
We're already doing all the transparency stuff around the debt, the investments,
but we cannot get those stars until you get your first star,
which is the transparency portal and putting that five years of
historical data on there. So I would encourage this body, to encourage the
administration as a part of that project, to do the five years of historical
data so that we can in fact get we would probably get three
or four stars right off the bat. Thank you,
Controller. And I do believe we're hearing regular progress being made towards
that goal. So hopefully, Mr. Oliver, that addresses your first
question. And as to your second point about the words
I read at the beginning of the meeting, that coming from the administration
is not a new restriction, but really the
mayor focusing on amendments and trying to get ahead of those this
year by reminding council members in our offices
that policy amendments are not appropriate and will
not be considered and to focus on the budget.
So appreciating your comments. I want to thank you for being
here again and I believe that brings us to the conclusion
of the public speaking component of your presentation.
Control Are. Thank you very much for being here and
your whole team and thank
you so much. We'll take a short break before our next presentation
from the mayor's office. And with that, we'll take a brief
adjournment.